gemüse ist gesund aber wie ist es
gesünder roh oder gekocht
[Musik]
eisvogel hat uns gefragt gehen vitamine
beim kochen kaputt sehr gute frage
kleines mal waren kochen wir überhaupt
sagen wir so wir menschen sind mit
relativ kleinen szenen verhältnismäßig
schwachen kiefern und keinen besonders
starken verdauungssystem ausgestattet
will ich durch kochen zellulose oder
fleischfasern aufweichen würden dann
würde uns das viel zu viel energie beim
kauen und für dauer und kosten das food
roma hätte eine neue dimension
viele glauben dass gemüse roh gesünder
ist als gekocht aber was sagt eigentlich
die wissenschaft dazu es geht
tatsächlich vitaminen und antioxidantien
beim kochen kaputt vitamin c zum
beispiel überlegt kochen nur teilweise
zu machen zum beispiel verlieren nach
zwei minuten kochen etwa 10% vitamin c
dann haben schon kochen sind es
insgesamt etwa 30 prozent verloren gehen
auch die sogenannte polyphenole die in
vielen gemüsesorten vorkommen und das
risiko für krebs und
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen senken
verlieren beim kochen ihre antioxidative
wirkung und auch brokkoli isst wo
gesünder als gekocht ist irgendjemand
propos lierow jedenfalls zerstört die
hitze ein enzym das brokkoli anti krebs
wirkungen verleiht soweit gute
nachrichten für alle die nicht gerne
kochen e mail
doch so manches gemüse wird durchs
kochen für uns tatsächlich
nährstoffreicher die hitze setzt endlich
die robusten zellwände der pflanzen und
macht so nährstoffe frei die sonst an
diese zellwände gebunden sind wie wir
das beispiel auf vier erhöht kochen den
gehalt von beta carotin vitamin a
umgewandelt wird und auch den gehalt von
lycopin
ist wie beta carotin auch ein roter
farbstoff der komfort vor allem in
tomaten wassermelone paprika und wird
mit einem verminderten risiko für krebs
und herzinfarkt in verbindung gebracht
manche forscher sehen in die kopien
sogar ein stärkeres antioxidans als im
vitamin c
da vitamin c häufiger in obst vorkommt
dass wir aero essen und nikotin häufiger
in gemüse dass wir eben auch korn ist
die kombination von obst und gemüse eine
gute sache wie eure mama auch schon
immer gesagt hat nehmen möge geben uns
auf spinat pilze sparen kohl oder
paprika insgesamt mehr nährstoffe wenn
man sie kocht oder gar gemüse branchen
und vor allem frittieren ist wer hätte
es gedacht leider nicht so gesund nicht
nur wegen des fettgehaltes sondern auch
beim frittieren das öl ständig aktiviert
wird und dabei freie radikale
diese 33 dekade sind nicht nur schick
sondern verbrauchen auch die ganzen
antioxidantien aus dem gemüse auf die
iren nicht mehr für uns übrig bleiben es
gibt sehr in forschung dazu ich könnte
jetzt noch viele weitere studien
aufzählen die die vor und nachteile von
gekochtem gemüse untersucht haben am
ende ist nur wichtig gemüse ist gesund
und wenn wir es so zubereiten dass es
uns besser schmeckt dann essen wir
natürlich auch mehr davon
und das ist die hauptsache schön schlau
vielen dank eisvogel für deine schön
schlau frage wenn ihr noch fragen habt
schreibt sie in die kommentare und lasst
euch bitte wissen was ihr denkt was auf
meinem dieser drauf ist ist dass wir
euch einen kaktus oder ein brokkoli oder
was ganz anderes schreibt die kommission
bis demnächst